over the past year there has been a lot
of speculation
about you guys where do you guys stand
right now well now it's at a point where
i
read that you guys were crying on set or
things got very emotional on set of the
video
we've lived through these moments left
everyone speechless
it made me sad that you called her
america's sweetheart and you the bad guy
for like it's like the natural persona
assumptions like oh this guy's
the piece he's the bad guy there's so
much to celebrate i feel like in your
life right now
let's start with single number three
america's
sweetheart i feel so alone in the
crowded
place the video has almost eight
million views right now on youtube it's
crazy i mean how are you feeling about
the reception of the song i mean
honestly it's unreal and i
i didn't even think any of this would
happen the way it like
it all happened but it's
been amazing so far
[Music]
who has inspired you the most and how
would you kind of describe
the music that you're making i've gotten
so much inspiration from
many different artists a lot of travis
and mgk's new stuff
a lot of uh the early 2000s and um
a lot of like classic rock stuff like
that so i've been um
i've been taking a little bit of
inspiration from all over the place and
kind of uh
seeing where it gets me you actually you
worked with travis barker on the eulogy
of
you and me right how was it to work
with him knowing that he was such an
influence to you
um honestly crazy as hell he's been
working with me on this entire album
that's going to be coming this summer
he worked with me on 21st and uh the
olympia viewing me and
he did a killer job and like the drums
really speak for themselves like travis
is just a god at what he does
he's a maniac i mean i've seen him a few
times play live
and i am always like how do your arms
go that fast oh it's the same it's the
same in the studio
like is it really yes he's he's just mad
at what he does and
it's it's insane to watch did he give
you any advice
on either making music or on
fame he'll he'll talk about like little
things while we're in the studio that i
just pick up on but anytime that he
opens his mouth everyone in the room
just listens
you know what i mean he's one of those
people he's just so wise that everyone
just listens to what he has to say
it's so funny because i feel like him
and courtney are like the mom and dad of
the tick tock world right now dude
their relationship i love it i think
it's so cute i
do i i ship it
let's go back to america's sweetheart i
guess
what does this song mean to you you've
said it's autobiographical
you've said it's your most personal song
you've ever written
about the worst night in your life
basically like right in the beginning of
quarantine when we all got locked up
it was just a really time for me i'd
just gotten out of a relationship
and i was not allowed to leave my house
and so i felt very alone during this
time
and me and the person that we had uh
split with which is charlie
we just decided to be friends and it was
really hard for the two of us
during quarantine when i started
songwriting i was like why don't i just
be real with everybody
and it came to this point where i was
like well this is one of like
the worst nights of my life why don't i
channel this certain emotion and write
about it
was it hard for you to get to that place
or was it almost i guess therapeutic in
a way
honestly it felt like relieving writing
the song it kind of flowed out of me
pretty naturally i wrote it in about an
hour
wow the whole song that's amazing
the video i feel like is so visual it
starts off with charlie
literally pulling you out of what i
think is a grave
yeah yeah what does that symbolize
it's her pulling me out of the ground
and like saving me from
all of uh like this pain that the world
like
has given me i guess i read that you
guys were crying on set or things got
very emotional on set of the video
yeah i don't know there's something
about the
the slow date scene that was just so
moving like
i could feel charlie's hands like
shaking in my arms i was like oh my god
like this is so sad i mean there's so
much emotion
for for everyone it's like like this is
it's not even like
real should we like this is real life
like
we've lived through these moments and so
being able to like
hear this song and hear the actual
emotional value that it has
while we just like sit there and like
literally rock back and forth that's
what slow dancing is
it's like it was just powerful i guess
it
left everyone speechless
[Music]
sometimes people forget that this is
actual real life
over the past year there has been a lot
of speculation
about you guys where do you guys stand
right now well now it's at a point where
where we become friends and been able to
mature
and uh grow together because of like
everything that the internet has done
like we we just kind of have
been able to maturely make a decision
that we should just be friends and
kind of uh stay strong and just like
live our lives you know we're there
we're very there for each other and we
still connect on a
very deep level like we have a great
friendship going on
and um yeah i don't know i feel like no
one will ever experience what you guys
have experienced with
the tick tock of it all and experiencing
this burst of fame at the same time
and it's it must be wild to see how the
internet i guess
impacted your friendship your
relationship whatever it may be
was that hard yeah i mean
the internet i feel like makes it really
hard for for people today it brings such
a spotlight on things
and uh it can like intensify things and
make things more stressful so for
certain people i have like
i have a friend uh nick austin who's
been
like dating someone and just doing his
thing and having like a private relation
relationship like he he's so much
happier
handling it privately i guess is that
what you think you'll do
with your next relationship i don't know
i don't know if
when if or when there is a next
relationship but
maybe let's go back to the song though i
mean it is inspired by her
you said that in your eyes what makes
her
america's sweetheart well um
to the internet and to like her persona
she's she's just been the sweet kid from
the go like literally
not like not a flaw just a very sweet
like outgoing bubbly human being like
that's
that's that's charlie that's who she is
and so
being able to find the right word for
that like hearing
america sweetheart it's like oh like
this makes sense
and it and it did the first time it came
to my head i'm the bad guy
in your america's sweetheart
it made me sad that you called her
america's sweetheart
and you the bad guy because i feel like
in a lot of ways
you're also a sweetheart just so many
people and even just talking to you
why would you call yourself that well i
mean a lot of people have their own
perception on me or who i am and
just like what they think i am as a
person
and um and a lot of people just think
i'm i'm a bad guy
before they even get to know me so for
like it's like the natural
persona assumption it's like oh this
guy's the piece
he's the bad guy this is america's
sweetheart you know what i mean
i'm sorry that you felt that people
thought that
[Laughter]
do you feel like that's shifting a
little bit i mean i hope
how did she feel about the song when she
heard it the first time knowing that it
was
about her oh i told her straight away i
was just like hey like
i want to tell you it's like i want to
show you a song
like i wanted to tell you what it's
about and uh
she cried the first time she listened to
it that's so sweet
she's a sweetheart as you've been
i guess releasing music and going
through a pandemic your career
continuing to skyrocket
what have you learned most about
yourself
over the past year or so
um i feel like i've learned i've learned
a lot i've learned
um patience i've really learned myself a
lot like
i really got been able to find myself
find where i want to go to next which
like helped me find and come to music
really like it gave me the
the time and the chance to really figure
myself out there
and that like take those eight months to
to write and to get in the studio and
all that kind of stuff
like that's something i wouldn't have
been able to just even
think about if quarantine wasn't a thing
america's sweetheart
while sat in tone i i think also shows
proof that you can come out of the other
side
of a dark time in a way i guess
was that also part of the message you
were hoping to put out there
and how do you think you pulled yourself
out of that dark time
well i really pulled myself out of a
dark time
through music really being able to
to write and to just be in the studio
all the time and gave me like
a heartwarming feeling and um it was
very very
therapeutic for me to to just sit in the
studio and write for hours
was it liberating or scary
to be so vulnerable about your life and
and what you've been going through as
you were just writing for hours oh god i
mean dude it was
it was so like this is probably my most
vulnerable song by like
a mile like the song
it is it's just so like minimalist to
the way that i'm
just being vulnerable in every word that
that i like put into that song it's
it i don't even know how to explain it
you said it's your most vulnerable but
you also told me that your album is
coming this summer
i didn't tell you that is i'm so excited
to hear this album by the way
is it done is it almost done what's
inspiring the whole
album well um what really inspired this
project
is like my entire life i've been through
a lot of
relationships and i really wanted to
talk about all of them but not in any
order
and i wanted to i wanted to just write
an entire album just based off of
my my love life and like how it's gone
and how it usually goes and then like
each of them
each song portrays a certain emotion
that ties
into like taps into a certain emotion
for each song and it's all in order
and it's just one long story and it's um
it's great
having used your your entire love life
not just the one relationship
as inspiration i guess what do you feel
like you've learned most
about love as you reflect on all those
and as well um i've learned
i've learned a lot about love i i feel
like
love is something that's you definitely
need to be patient with
and it's it's a it's a hard thing and it
takes a lot a lot of time
it's not easy but take your time and if
it's
it's right it's right i feel i can
correct me if i'm wrong but i get the
sense that you're a guy who
loves love i
i do love love and i'm i'm i guess like
a hopeless romantic
i am very i'm very patient with
who i pick and choose and you know
i'm not in any rush is there anyone that
you're dying to work with are we going
to get a travis
collab an mgk collab i
i have no idea what who i'm going to
collab with in the future
but um i
would i'm dying to do a collab i'm dying
who who's your number one on the top of
the wish list
um maybe you like green day probably
green day
that would be so epic i feel like you
could make that happen
when i was at the hype house you did
tell me that you wanted to get into
music
i love that quarantine sort of enabled
you to
to get to the point where you can make
music a focus
do you feel like it's all happening what
what do the next five years of your
music
i guess look like in your mind
well um at this point in time i don't
really know
because i'm just literally just starting
out it's it's all crazy and it's all
new to me and so uh with it being so
fresh i have no idea what the next five
days looks like
but i'm more than excited to see where
it takes me
will you go on tour once the pandemic is
over
yes yes that's that's all i want to do i
want to get on the road so bad
i want to travel and see everyone like
that's like the best feeling
about making music and having people
that support you is being able to like
hug them and
show them like love back that they give
to you i feel like you're in such a good
place i feel like you just
seem so mature right now and so well
spoken and i do feel like you
thank you you're really coming to your
own it's so nice
yeah it's taking me a while i mean i've
grown up a little bit and i've started
hanging out with more like
adults and stuff so it's been
i've been maturing a little bit it's
it's no secret too
that you are a heartthrob i mean
millions of people
follow you how how does it feel having
that title i mean
are you embracing the fans and the fame
does it ever feel
rough um i i love
all the love that they give me it's it's
honestly flattering um
but i never know what to do about it i'm
just like oh thank you guys like
i love you how would you describe your
album in three words
um
uh
three words three words okay um i would
describe it as
love their love is definitely one of
them um
heartbreak and
angst like half album it's about like
not not just love but about the
heartbreaks
like about the bad times and like both
the good and the bad
and like the middle in between like
there's there's two sides
to the story it's cool
you